welcome back to cbs this morning prince
william is responding to prince harry
and megan startling claims in sunday's
interview with oprah
in london this morning william was asked
point blank
is the royal family racist he said the
royals are in his words
very much not a racist family other
officials are now pushing for a wider
debate of the racism issue
focusing on tabloid newspaper coverage
of megan in particular
let's go back to holly williams in
london with more on this story holly
good morning to you again
good morning a group of female members
of parliament is expected to call for a
debate
into how britain's tabloid media has
covered megan
duchess of sussex the debate would take
place here at the united kingdom's
houses
of parliament the center of power in
this country
holly lynch is one of the female members
of parliament who wants a public debate
into how megan has been treated
by britain's powerful tabloid newspapers
there's a real sense that she was an
outsider that she wasn't good enough for
our royal family
just a constant constant tearing down of
her character
in her tell-all interview the duchess
also accused royal aides of failing to
stand up for her
when the papers got it wrong everyone in
the institution knew it wasn't so why
didn't somebody just say that it's a
good question
harry made the extraordinary claim that
his family
the royal family was fearful of the
tabloid media
with that relationship and that that
control and the fear by the
by the uh by the uk um tabloids it's a
really
it's a toxic environment there's no
doubt that megan has been vilified by
britain's tabloid papers
their coverage sometimes blatantly
racist
but harry singled out one group of
people in this country
that has stood up for the couple over 70
members of parliament female members of
parliament
called out the articles and headlines
written about megan
yet no one from my family ever said
anything over those three years
oh that hurts this is the letter written
to megan by female members of parliament
in 2019
taking aim at the outdated colonial
undertones of some reporting
and saying they share an understanding
of the abuse and intimidation
holly lynch wrote the letter that we've
got a responsibility to them so it's not
only about stepping in to try and
protect the duchess of sussex
but to all those young women who'll be
feeling utterly let down by the nature
of those headlines
and feeling powerless if they were in
the same situation
the executive director of the society of
editors a group that defends media
freedom
said on monday that the press here is
quote not bigoted and that it was not
acceptable for the duke and duchess to
make such claims
without providing any supporting
evidence he's now resigned
following a backlash from journalists
anthony holly williams in london yeah
and this is something we've talked about
here
because i mean we don't see it in this
country obviously it's the press over
there
but she she endured some really vicious
attacks well i also think megan has
plenty of receipts meaning that she's
been keeping track of things and all you
need to do
is look at the headlines we've been
looking at all year it's one after the
other i can remember one that said
straight out of compton that her mother
was from the wrong side of tracks with
dreadlocks
remember the avocado yeah when kate has
avocado she's doing it for the baby
yes when megan does uh it's it's ruining
the rainforest and
and uh and global desecration and saying
that she's from gangster royalty i mean
that's just there's definitely a
difference in the coverage so at least
you have to acknowledge that and i think
that's part of the problem with them
no one ever acknowledges that this is
happening and now
now what i like is that there is a
microscope on it everybody's paying
attention to it i was
draw your own conclusions i was struck
at how politely the question was asked
of prince william this morning
is the royal family racist is the royal
family a racist family
sir oh yes and he said it's very much
not racist now when you just play that
clip
it sounds strange but when you hear the
question that he was asked i think he
was wanted to emphasize no we are not
racist
all right